all right i'm rolling mr jane
this is called
i never did dream of being arrested
i never didn't want to be a wrestler
and i had a few ups
and lord knows how many downs
i never knew my father he got killed in
a dice game
shooting dice
no i didn't graduate from school i'm a
ninth grade dropout
all the things i went through in
wrestling
wasn't with me become an arrest
when kamala came to the ring the kids
ran away from him
he scared him people thought he may have
been a dangerous man on the loose
i wanted to be a truck driver i couldn't
find a job
so i say uh i think i'm just gonna go to
rest
oh yeah you're the big guy yeah i mean
you do good in the wrestling they told
me that wrestling
was not real the day before i got in the
ring
and when i met jerry lawlor he said look
how would you like to make more money
than you ever made in your life
he told me sir i got this gimmick for
you it's a
big black guy from uganda
i've never been to you again he gonna
have his
face painted his nipple painted
i made my stand in the ring and i tapped
that
big belly he acted as if he was scared
to death
he's the one that created me
and i don't want to create those chops i
just started doing those chops
i feel great the way that people would
scream last lawler with a right hand now
he's on him one
two three he beat him the new southern
heavyweight
champ that was the birth of kamala
six feet nine inches 385 pounds
of kemala the ugandan giant
working with andre back in 1982
and we got in the rain i did what they
told me it was a mix-up problem with the
referee
and that's when i nailed it bam
i'm sorry oh i don't think
i don't think boss i said
well you know you better get the
ticket from now on
i carried it for andre i carried it for
up until after andre that
whipped in at the 15 minute mark and
down goes kamala one two and that's
going to be
it wow i think i could uh make a good
case for kamala being in the hall of
fame not only
because he had the uh the very memorable
and lucrative run with uh hulk hogan but
because he was one of those guys who
drew money literally everywhere he went
kamala coming off the ropes look out
it could be all over right here now
hogan told me one time i hoped you're
getting your money cause i'm getting
mine
because you putting the asses on the
suit hulk hogan wrestled come out for
six months
but hope made the money earthen morgan
was making a killing he said look i know
you ain't making a lot of money up here
look at the majority asked me where was
i staying at that night
i was almost there at uh some old motel
around they were jumping out there
he said you come over with me he said
hell i don't have to pay for it
let's pay for all my stuff i wasn't
making no money
vince told me sir i think you're doing
all right
anytime you want to leave things you're
welcome to go
so that was the end of that
vince mcmanus is your boss he's not your
friend and you got to keep that
distinction in mind
i wish things had worked out better for
me i believe the reason i got done that
way is because
i'm just a poor boy from down south
mississippi
if i hadn't been a better talker
knew how to negotiate that
probably would have helped me
we got in this business we thought
it was going to turn into a gold mine
it just don't turn out that way
and she had told me before the answer
body parts you gonna start losing body
parts
i didn't believe that
when i came home i would look down
and i would cry a little bit
uh i figured
i'm not known manny i'm sorry but
i'm not known anymore
and people gonna treat me like i'm not
known
but i made it through
i made it through kamala being a hard
time
shows that it can happen to anybody
because here's a guy who did not live
lavishly
life is tough you know and famous
fleeting i'm learning to deal with it
more and more and every day
that i come out here and i will say
hello world
what a beautiful green earth
that god hail for us i don't want people
to feel sorry for me
because i'm still kamala i will always
be kamala
you